let's get to chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett he joins us
from our Washington bureau major good
morning good morning at times
Bob Muller seemed to frustrate members
of both parties so I I wonder did either
side get what they were looking for in
this testimony well for the Democrats
the priority was to try to establish
bit-by-bit fact by fact in a methodical
sometimes plodding way but nevertheless
creating a wide public record that can
be reviewed and gone back to over and
over again about actions the president
took that sound obstructive but might
not be legally but certainly outside the
bounds of what the normal conduct when
American president is and also go
through methodically as well all the
various contacts during the campaign
between people close to the president
and Russians contacts at the time denied
but later established through the
special counsels report that body of
work Democrats believe hadn't really
been presented to the public in this
sort of forum that was their goal and in
large measure on the substance of that
they achieved that Republicans wanted to
portray Robert Muller as not very strong
witness someone unfamiliar with some of
the underlying details of the report and
under unfamiliar with some of the
allegations of bias either within the
investigation itself or in its origins
and on that score
Republicans believe they achieved
success major mother made it very clear
that Russian interference is certainly
not over do you think or do you get the
sense that this administration is taking
that very seriously well it's hard to
get that impression Gail from the public
utterances of the president but there
are those within the administration who
say this is a priority though the
president doesn't make it sound that way
when he talks about it or engages with
Vladimir Putin the head of the Russian
government and it's clear
every time the robert muller has given
the opportunity he says to america this
is a serious issue it will happen again
and it's worth noting our own partisan
divisions which lead us recently to
believe the worst about each other help
the Russians achieve their goal which is
to create division in America and create
a sense that our own system isn't as
strong as it should be we help the
Russians even though we might not intend
all right
pay attention to that thank you very
much major